[تصفيق]
عده وقفت على هذه المنصه تبعت محطات زمنيه
واحدث التغييرا جذريا بسير الازمات رؤساء
امريكيون اعتلوا منبر الكونغرس وادلب
خطابات حفرت في الذاكره احدها ادخل
الولايات المتحده الحرب العالميه الثانيه
من ديسمبر
1941 طلب الرئيس الثاني والثلاثون
فرانكلين روزفلت من الكونغرس اعلان الحرب
على اليابان اثر هجوم
ونانا الموافقه الفوريه ثلاثه تعديلات
ادخلها روسفلت على الصياغه ليبدا كلامه
باليوم الذي سيعيش في العار
50 عاما بعدها خطاب نصر ادلى به الرئيس
جورج بوش الاب في السابع والعشرين من
فبراير
1991 اعلن خلاله تحرير الكويت اثرى عمليه
خاطفه اجبلت القوات العراقيه على الانسحاب
بالقوه من الاراضي الكويتيه بعد استنفاذ
جهود اقناع صدام حسين بالخروج الطوعيه
[تصفيق]
ا لكنه ايد عام 95 ما عرف بسياسه الرفع
والضربه في ما يخص حرب البوسنه متحدثا
بنبره غاضبه ممزوجته
مرحله اخرى رسمتها احداث سبتمبر عام 2001
حرب على الارهاب كما سماها الرئيس الاسباق
جورج بوش فصولها في استمرار
ماشي شويه
في بعض الاحيان تصرفات عفويه او مقصوده
كما حصل مع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
حين مزقت رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي